je suis pas frileux mais là j'ai jamais
vu ça je gèle j'ai l'impression que mes
pieds vont devenir des glaçons on
m'avait dit que c'était à 0 mais c'est
au moins à -20 ce truc-là comprends même
pas comment isabelle a fait pour rentrer
dedans c'est vrai que froid concerne la
viande bas ils sont les fléaux la [ __ ]
jamais vraiment des minables jean michel
maire et jean michel maire je vous le
dis a failli passer parce que je vais
expliquer ce qui paraît donc hors était
fou de rage en disant mais quel con mais
quel con parce que i thought et les
guerres des courants en dessous qui
peuvent les entraîner sous la glace et
quand ils remontent il se cogne contre
la glace vraiment vu morts alors qu'une
autre occasion et qui parce qu il fait
tellement froid et qu'il tombe dans les
pommes
il coule états unis il passe sous la
glace une fois que vous êtes sous la
glace fini c'est terminé
moi j'ai mon nom qu'il a eu c'est la
jonquère ils ont dit on vous l'a dit moi
cela m'est arrivé un jour j'ai dû à
chercher une boîte à outils lol non mais
je vous dis non je vous jure qu'il a
failli mourir cette espèce de mal